[Applause]
what else you want to talk about pat
mcafee again
shout out to pat mcafee man pat pat pat
congratulations huge duel
duel
huge deal uh
looking like 30 m's a year i think 30
m's a year for four years so 120 million
total wow now he's got to pay out
everybody from that but that's 120
million dollars i mean that's big time
the guy deserves it i mean
he is
he is like he's the perfect combination
it's like you always want an athlete to
be talking about sports yeah there's
something about an athlete talking about
sports it just seems it's credibility
yeah right but um he's also someone who
would have been able to do this even if
he wasn't an athlete yes he's that good
at it yes so it's really great to be
that good and have the credibility of
being athlete it's like i gotta go here
first and if you're a player i imagine
you want to talk to a guy who's been
illegal
he gets even if you look at punters like
they're not a part of it first they were
there first of all he was there second
of all his co-host is aj hawk who was a
linebacker for the packers right first
round pick this guy knows the [ __ ] is up
yeah so
he just brilliantly done it this is
great to see man it's just great to see
they built that thing and just him and
his team just bravo bravo i didn't know
that they were doing it every day of the
week five days a week dude five days a
week so good for him but it's just
awesome i love to see this i love to see
someone build something on their own
something that they're passionate about
and then be able to make life-changing
uh i mean generational wealth dude the
craziest thing this is a spotify deal
without spotify
yeah usually it's a spotify deal or if
so whatever company deal and your
podcast has to move exclusively there
yeah this is just a sponsorship from
fanduel who already sponsored him and
from what i've heard i heard a little
bit of the show betting is intimately is
a part of the show and they will shout
out fanduel and they will push it but
fanduel is like we just want to keep you
do everything else the same have it on
all the platforms we're giving you 30
million a year to just keep doing you
yeah do all your other ads i assume
because they they do have other
sponsorships i liquid death is a sponsor
i can't imagine fanduel being like you
can't have water sponsors what would
they give a [ __ ]
maybe that's a that'd be an interesting
thing to look into he's also a cool dude
he donated like three months
six million of it oh six million yeah
beginning it was just three million but
now he's up to six million just to like
his local high school like children's
hospitals like
athletic teams that needed money like
he's just supporting his communities
that he grew up in and lived in wow
that's fine
i wish i had sent you the tweet but it
was sad to see dave portnoy tweeted some
real like kind of snarky [ __ ] what is
that basically he said like
he kind of was like i gave pat this
playbook i taught him how to get bet on
sports and like without me there is no
without me and barcelo there is no pat
mcafee which is true pat mcafee started
on barstool but they left on good terms
pat was basically just like yo i'm
working in indianapolis i'm not moving
to new york things are getting lost in
translation i need to be on my own and
then built this thing into something
[ __ ] crazy and dave could have just
been like yo it's good to see one of our
own doing it you know what i mean and
then he was just kind of snarky about
the whole thing and then pat to his
credit all about positivity was just
like hey thanks for the you know thanks
for the first shot boss or whatever on
moving forward or whatever like he just
said something nice back but it was just
kind of disappointing like dave you're
good dog yeah pat's always been a nice
dude i knew him back when i was working
in indianapolis oh really yeah so i was
at bob and tom where like pat kind of
started at least in my opinion started
like a lot of his broadcasting stuff is
that babaton was a local radio show in
indianapolis and he was like the biggest
local celebrity so they would have him
on all the time and so he would come on
and he was like doing stand-up at the
same time i saw him like do his first
few like headlining sets like at morty's
in indianapolis and after the show was
like i was just a kid and i would like
go and hang out i was probably like 18
at the time and he was like super
friendly like would just sat me down
like was talking to me like like an
after-party thing like the ball right
dude he like played soccer and he was
like bro you played soccer at odp
growing up like he was just like a super
nice dude i ended up like tweeting him i
was like dude great meeting you like hit
me back he was like yeah man that's so
dope
stay in touch like he was always a nice
dude and i'm pretty sure he retired
early to do barstool
like i don't think barstool was that big
when he went there either he was just
like he saw the opportunity he saw where
he fit in he's you know why he had like
a couple of knee surgeries i think he
was in bad shape physically yeah to be a
punter but he had a good contract it was
14 million and then he walked away from
it and then went to barstool not that
year but that was the total content how
much was oh totally i think he had a few
million left on it but he just walked
away from him and said i'm gonna do this
thing and now he built it into he gets
paid like an nfl quarterback now how
crazy is that to make more money
being a broadcaster than you do
playing the sport you're broadcasting
not only yeah you make more money than
anyone on your team made
wow i doubt quarterbacks are making 30
million retired yeah that's true wow
[ __ ] wild yeah good for him yeah good
for him man shout out to pat we need you
on the podcast pack 100 next time you're
in new york you got to pull up yeah no
zoom come through yeah yeah pull the
[ __ ] up